when I take an image
[Music]
music just plays in my head I don't know
if that works for everyone else but
that's just how it works are made I
sound crazy but it's the honest truth
the photography that I particularly love
is just being able to like capture a
moment
and then other people will be able to
feel exactly what you felt when you took
the picture
foreign
[Music]
I like this because it's kind of like
a perspective of what you're probably
doing there's nobody here I feel like
photography allows me to show the
beautiful side of New Haven as well as
the real side that other people need to
see to make all of it beautiful
I used to attend um Achievement First
Amazon high on Dixwell I'm 18 years old
and
um I love photography this one's my
favorite the thing with Amazon is that
Adam Assad it's a college prep school so
they don't really focus particularly on
the Arts programs so as far as a
photography club or a photography class
there was nothing of the source so I was
really kind of frustrated to not be able
to have a space to share with other kids
and other colleagues and other people in
the community of our like skills and our
artistic sides
foreign
of the world that the museum could play
in the community and that we actually
need to to come out and be more
proactive in what we offer to people
that feels relevant to them and that
feels like a point of connection
[Music]
from here began because I was curating
an exhibition with Paul Messier at The
Institute for the preservation of
cultural heritage about the artist Bill
brand and the artist Henry Moore and how
they came together through photography
my counselor was like hey there's like
this photography program that Yale is
throwing and they're interested in some
students and you know you should apply
we opened up competitive application
system where we invited students who are
enrolled in in what we called greater
New Haven High School students and
first-year college students and we
thought we might get a mix of people who
are at that point in their lives where
they're thinking about what they want to
do I applied I got an email a couple
days later saying that we saw our
application and we would like to
interview you to be a part of the
internship and I was shocked because I
did I didn't do this like seriously
because I didn't think I'd be called
back we had a really good response to
the call for applications from a huge
variety of schools in the greater New
Haven area it was exactly what we hoped
for it was like a roller coaster
promotions it was like from I'm not
taking this seriously it's you I'm super
excited that I actually got into the
program and then from there it was just
a great time
hi Sarah
hi Bob how's it going absolutely love
all of the instructions there I
absolutely love Bob Hixson Sarah was uh
very impressive
as a person
and also her photography I think this
was shot at the lowest at my lunch can
go I have a 1.4 lens so I was like let
me experiment with that aperture this is
one of my favorites that you did this
year sometimes they taught me when it
comes to
content and meaning and story
they were very good with telling stories
in their photographs which is something
that that I admire and
I'm not always very good at it with Bob
on the outside he can seem you know
intimidating and like very serious but I
got to see the artistic you know
emotional sentimental side of him that
allowed me to be more comfortable with
reaching out to him as well the process
for Gathering our team that was teaching
the course was
I mean in a way sort of mirrored the
process of thinking about what we want
to do for the community what's our own
Community here within the museum we have
photographers you know who've been
practicing photographies for years
decades
so we wanted to bring them in as
they're experts in photography that
background
that's a that's a dynamite
treatment there teaching
on behalf of Yale
can be a little daunting thank you I
really appreciate that but her reaction
filled me with confidence
all right I can I can do this she's
connected ever since the program started
I've been just dreaming of the day that
we'll all be able to meet up it'd be
really cool to see the people that had
that impact on me and that gave me the
opportunity to venture out on my
photography side when I didn't have the
opportunity to do that in school
[Music]
I'm so excited for this exhibition we're
going to invite the students to come to
a to meet and greet a private viewing of
the exhibition in person so we'll meet
them in person for the first time you
look wonderful
thank you
[Music]
this is crazy it's good right yeah dark
to see these beautiful images projected
into the windows I hope that they are
all thrilled when they see their work
there it looks amazing like absolutely
stunning well we appreciate the trust
you put in us because you know it was an
experiment for us as well right hello hi
Bob I would hug you if I could I know
elbow yeah how's it going it's been such
a long time it's been a minute since
we've spoken yeah you're also very tall
too I didn't think you're gonna be his
song
[Music]
it's just nice to see that we get our
work somewhere the way that we're able
to communicate and look at our pictures
as if we did all this in person is I
guess it speaks with the experience of
like photography and art like although
we did it online we're here in person
and it's the feelings are natural and
it's just great I think it's amazing I
hope that the students will take away
from this course a sense of
self-confidence in their own artistic
abilities their own artistic discernment
and I know from conversations that I've
had with some of the students that they
they see photography differently now
these students Sarah
have so much going on are so capable in
many ways that I think they're all
destined to do great things
[Music]
um if I had a little bit to do with that
that's great
[Applause]
I will definitely remember this moment
in my life as life-changing and not to
be melodramatic but in all honesty it
did change my life to think that my
pictures from somebody from New Haven
somebody goes to a charter school down
the street has the ability to have their
pictures on the building it's a very
emotional feeling it's very it makes me
happy it makes me proud and it makes me
feel like accomplished
uh
[Music]